doch zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute.de für die einen ist instagram ja
so die tägliche mischung aus klatsch
privaten quatsch mode beauty und
vielleicht noch so ein bisschen
nachrichten für anderen ist instagram
die längste dauerwerbesendung der welt
denn eine ganze menge instrument zur
innen verdienen dort mit
produktempfehlungen und platzierungen
teilweise echt absurde summen von geld
aber wie ist das eigentlich wenn sie
ihren followern sachen zeigen die sie
selber gekauft haben wie sie aus
irgendeinem grund gut finden und
empfehlen möchten muss dann da auch
werbung drunter stehen das gab eine
ganze weile jetzt ziemlich große
rechtsunsicherheit es gab viele anzeigen
es gab viele klagen viele
gerichtsurteile
aber bislang nur auf den unteren
instanzen heute hat sich der
bundesgerichtshof das erste mal mit
dieser frage beschäftigt final hat ein
urteil gesprochen und verkündet das ja
was dabei rauskommt influenza rennen
unter umständen ja eventuell dann doch
nicht immer alles als werbung
kennzeichnen müssen aber wie das bei den
juristen so ist ist immer alles
schwieriger als es tatsächlich am ende
aussieht eine der drei beklagten um die
es heute ging ist kathi hummels mit der
sprechen wir hier gleich und werden sie
fragen was sie von dem urteil hält ob
sie erleichtert ist und wie das für sie
jetzt weitergeht aber vorher wird uns
rechtsanwalt michael terhaag das
juristisch immer auseinander nehmen und
das urteil versuchen so gut es geht zu
erklären so richtig viel wissen wir
tatsächlich noch nicht weil nicht die
urteilsbegründung noch fehlt aber das
was sie wissen werden wir versuchen
auseinanderzunehmen fragen und
kommentare zu dem thema ihr kennt das
wie immer in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder hier an diese e
mail adresse zdf heute.de zdf.de und
dann gucke ich was ich von euren fragen
mit rein nehmen kann aber wir fangen
erst mal mit einer kurzen erläuterung
worum es eigentlich geht von unserem
kollegen günther neufeld
auf instagram oder youtube erreichen sie
hunderttausende oder gar millionen in
finsteren die sich so präsentieren wie
ihre fans gern sein möchte
eine der bekanntesten kathi hummels
prominent auch wegen ihrer ehe mit dem
fußballer mats hummels
katie holmes und andere präsentieren bei
ihren auftritten produkte und weisen
auch auf die hersteller hin wenn sie
dafür zahlen muss das als werbung
gekennzeichnet werden so das gesetz
doch was gilt wenn eben für unser
produkte ohne honorar anpreisen
vielleicht in der hoffnung auf spätere
werbeverträge auch das sei
kennzeichnungspflicht die bewerbung
meinte ein verband von
wettbewerbsschützer und reichte klage
ein der bundesgerichtshof aber sieht das
anders
das gericht hat festgehalten das
werbliche postings bei social media
bereichen immer dann als werbung
gekennzeichnet werden müssen wenn man
dafür entweder geld oder vielleicht das
beworbene produkt oder irgendein anderes
geschenk bekommt man das alles selber
bezahlt hat und keine gegenleistung
bekommt muss man auch keine werbung dran
schreiben so das gericht bei kathi
hummels lief alles korrekt sie hat den
prozess gewonnen nächstes jahr tritt
auch eine gesetzliche klarstellung in
kraft von werbung kann künftig nur die
rede sein wenn entweder geld fließt oder
produkte verschenkt wurden
wir haben schon mehrfach gesehen bei uns
ist jetzt im stream michael terhaag
fachanwalt für gewerblichen rechtsschutz
it-recht einen schönen guten abend hallo
und so wir haben gerade versucht kurz
zusammenzufassen was erlaubt ist und was
nicht aber wir haben im vorgespräch
schon mal geklärt klingt einfach ist es
tatsächlich nicht jetzt haben wir die
gelegenheit das urteil mal ein bisschen
genauer auseinander zu nehmen also ich
fasse mal zusammen wenn ich als
influenza mit ein paar zehntausend
100.000 follower an geld kriege um ein
produkt in die kamera zu halten muss
sich bewerbungen darunter schreiben in
allen anderen fällen nicht ist es so
einfach
tatsächlich so einfach ist es wieder
nicht aber das kann man so als erster
anhaltspunkt sicherlich mal mitnehmen
ist eben wir beitrag leben ja auch schon
angesprochen worden bislang liegen auch
nur die grundsätzlichen entscheidungen
die der ausgang das ergebnis fest liegt
vor und es sind auch drei verschiedene
verfahren also sind muss man da auch
leider wieder ein bisschen auseinander
chlamydien und die urteilsgründe liegen
auch noch nicht vor also wir müssen
schon mit dem arbeiten was er bislang
haben das sind die eben die 33
entscheidungen die müsste man sich kurz
im einzelfall mal dazu anschauen dann
fange bei der ersten mal an da ging es
um eine influenza in die hat eine
marmelade irgendwie platziert und hat
das nichts zumindest nach dem willen
oder nach der nach dem klageführer nicht
ausreichend gekennzeichnet was hat der
bgh da gesagt ja genau das ist der fall
wo unstreitig tatsächlich geld geflossen
ist das heißt da ist also steht nicht
zur debatte dass man sich vielleicht
irgendwas selber gekauft hat oder oder
eben nicht oder es einfach nur so als
private meinung gemeinten gesagt hat
sogar da ist tatsächlich ein geldwerter
vorteil in welcher form auch immer
geflossen
in dem text unter dem posting hieß es
irgendwie wird die marmelade oder das
produkt angepriesen werden super sache
und morgen morgen gibt es dazu auch die
werbung auf der website also das ist
schon wirklich der der spannendste fall
fast weil das nord werbung des
stichworts ist tatsächlich verwendet
worden aber es hat der bgh
offensichtlich nicht gereicht um das
hier hinreichend kennzeichen zu
kennzeichnen als kommerzielles posting
und da dürfen uns wirklich auch
hoffnungen auf die runde machen dass
vielleicht der bgh wirklich auch mal so
weit geht dass er sagt ja hätte es so
gemacht dann wäre es gut gewesen so was
uns jedenfalls nicht gereicht das heißt
das ist alles noch nicht so ganz
eindeutig wie das gekennzeichnet werden
muss bei uns hier im fernsehen zum
beispiel guten machen hat internet fern
sind aber im normalen idealen fernsehen
wenn der block kommt dann steht da
muster immerfort stehen achtung jetzt
kommt werbung und am ende steht wieder
jetzt kommt keine werbung mehr gehen sie
davon aus dass es zum beispiel ähnlich
so läuft das zum beispiel dann gesagt
wird ok es muss am anfang des postings
fed anzeige oder werbung drinstehen wäre
das eine denkbare mögliche lösung
ja dass sie aktuell schon so dass je
transparenter man das macht umso mehr
ist man auf die auf der sicheren seite
da haben sie sich also die leute mit den
wildesten
formulierungen versucht irgendwo auch
ganz hinten dass man erst klicken muss
es ist auch nicht die aufgabe vom bgh
der bgh muss diesen konkreten fall
entscheiden er könnte aber wenn er
wollte zum beispiel wenn er nur so ein
schlenker macht und sagt ja wenn das
wort vorne mit dem hashtag verlinkt
gestanden hätte hätten wir die sache
vielleicht anders beurteilt dann würde
das natürlich ein klarer hinweis darauf
dass man das wenn man es denn so machen
würde um auf der sicheren seite gewesen
wäre aber kurzum ich sag jetzt mal vorne
als erstes wort hashtag werbung hashtag
anzeige in großbuchstaben dick wenn es
geht dann ist man auf der sicheren seite
viel mehr weiß man aber noch jetzt
aktuell leider noch nicht aber
nichtsdestotrotz muss man davon ausgehen
wenn jetzt jemand mit mehreren
hunderttausend voller waren im druck in
die die kamera hält und auch dann sagt
habe ich selber gekauft irgendwie für
mich als medienkonsument habe ich dann
trotzdem immer das gefühl er ist das
trotzdem irgendwie werbung also warum
meinen sie ist das jetzt tatsächlich
dann der fall dass man das nicht
reinschreiben muss nur weil man dann
sagt er habe ich selbst bezahlt ja da
kommt können wir eigentlich schon
unmittelbar auf den zweiten fall
übergehen wo es nämlich genau so gewesen
ist da ist auch eine junge dame mit ich
glaube 1,7 millionen verloren preist
irgendwas an und hat dafür unstreitig
kein geld bekommen das ist ja genau im
grunde genommen genau der fall da würde
jeder auch denken da stimmt doch etwas
nicht und so aber in dem fall ist es
offensichtlich so gewesen und
da der bgh jetzt vergleichsweise klipp
und klar schon das hat einen termin war
ich selbst zugegen auch schon so leicht
angedeutet aber hat wirklich gesagt nein
ich will dass unterscheidungskriterium
haben im regelfall wenn geld geflossen
ist oder zum beispiel das produkt
geschenkt wird oder eine teure reise
oder sowas dann ist das für mich werbung
ansonsten im regelfall nicht aber auch
hier gilt wieder im regelfall es sei
denn in gewissen werblicher überhang
erfolg also eine reine positive
darstellung
wirklich übertriebenes anpreisen des
produktes sowas kann dann auch wieder in
den hammer in die andere richtung
schlagen lassen was er gesagt hat das
bloße taktik setzen also das verlinken
auf einen anderen instagram account noch
nicht für diesen werblichen überschuss
spricht einen link auf die website
allerdings wahrscheinlich schon und so
ein gewerblicher überschuss oder das
heißt glaube ich in der pressemitteilung
übertrieben werblich das ist ja jetzt
auch so ein bisschen schwammig also
ist es im endeffekt dann doch wieder
eine einzelzelle frage wo man sich jeden
text und jedes in jedem wort love story
genau angucken müssen zu sagen so okay
das war jetzt einfach mal zu viel
ja das wird man auch danach wieder
festhalten können aber das haben nun mal
gesetze als auch gerichtsurteile eben
ansicht dass man da immer weiterkommen
da gibt es keinen gibt es keinen weg wie
es denn geht und wie es nicht geht
sondern es werden die einzelnen
entscheidungen
beurteilt und da liegen ja auch noch
drei beim bgh die dieses jahr
entschieden werden und aus dem gemenge
lage dieser geschichten wird man wird
man dann letztendlich eine richtschnur
ableiten können das ist ja wie ich
wollte nur schnell doch hinweisen dass
wenn ein posting rein positive ist also
wirklich ist ja mal 100 zeitungen die
die ein produkttest macht irgendwas was
nicht so schönes findet man da
eigentlich immer aber wenn wirklich ein
posting ausschließlich positiv produkt
hervorhebt dann hat das immer schon ein
bisschen geschmäckle und dann spricht
einiges eben für diesen werblichen
überschüssen aber wie will man denn
jetzt wirklich glaubhaft machen ich habe
da kein geld für bekommen also das wie
kann man das denn belegen dass es geht
ja im endeffekt nur wenn man seine
konten offen macht und sagt okay hier
ich habe mich zu bekommen und erst mal
böse gesprochen selbst dann gibt es
immer noch die möglichkeit
geldköfferchen hin- und herzuschieben
also wie kann man das tatsächlich als
influenza in glaubhaft machen nein ich
habe keine kohle dafür gekriegt
ja das ist letztendlich eine beweis
frage nennen ein teil des falles wird es
der influenza nicht tun müssen das wird
man eben auch noch ein bisschen abwarten
das ist auch die der große kritikpunkt
an dieser beurteilung wenn man es rein
einem geld fest macht denn wie ich immer
sage wenn man ein produkt teuer kaufte
den kaufbeleg torten ordnungsgemäß ab
heftet und sich dann große summen
übergehen keiner muss
bankkonten auflegen oder und der
geldkoffer gute idee naja das ist eben
praktisch noch nicht richtig umsetzbar
aber da ist man erst jetzt erstmal auf
dem weg
fragen katalog irgendwie aufzubauen oder
irgend kriterien zu finden das heißt im
endeffekt haben die
strafverfolgungsbehörden gar keine
handhabe wenn jemand sagt nein ich habe
dafür kein geld bekommen dann
tatsächlich dem das nachzuweisen doch
hast du
ja das ist jetzt gar keine straftat mit
strafrecht und straff geführten gar nix
zu tun polizei kümmert sich da auch
überhaupt nicht darum das ist sind ja
hier zivilverfahren das heißt ein
wettbewerber wie zum beispiel in dem
fall ist es jetzt einen verein der eben
die interessen von wettbewerbern
verfolgt der hat beweislast und der muss
das dann an schleppen und das ist ja
auch ein großer kritikpunkt dass man das
von der praxis her
schwer nachvollziehen kann also ich bin
auch immer derjenige dass auch
prominente die müssen auch mal eine
private meinung äußern dürfen die müssen
nicht jedes mal immer kennzeichnen
müssen aber wenn es doch dann relativ
eindeutigen
herausstellen dass stimmten produkt ist
vielleicht sogar noch die aufforderung
zum kauf ist dann muss man sowas auch
kennzeichen gucken wir uns vielleicht
mal an was der fall bei kathi hummels
war ich habe mir mal das profil von ihr
hier auf dem bildschirm geholt können
die kollegen vielleicht mal kurz drauf
schalten dann können uns das posting
angucken da sehen wir frau hummels in
modischer kleidung und sie steht hat
quasi eben das posting text geschrieben
ich gehe mit einem ich weiß nicht blitz
und viel orange in die neue woche
lebensfreude pur und dann steht da
runter von denen das foto ist von dem
haar und make-up waren und von denen das
outfit ist und diese firma hat jetzt
auch tatsächlich darunter auch noch
kommentiert in dem fall hat der bgh
jetzt gesagt da sie angibt sie hat das
alles selbst gekauft und hat kein geld
dafür bekommen darf sie das so machen
muss nicht anzeige zu unterschreiben
nichtsdestotrotz ist da ja ganz klar
benannt wer das ist
würden sie daraus trotzdem der kauf
empfehlung ableiten können
die den fall hat ja nun mal der bgh
leider nicht entschieden das ist mir
dass ich verstehe schon die in den
übergang in dem beispiel stand ja sogar
noch ausdrücklich anzeige insofern aber
ich habe mir das falsche ausgesucht den
schuldigen sie ja ein fehler also das
ist ein sorry das ist ging um den
elefanten wenn ich richtig ein richtig
böser schnitzer ja danke für den hinweis
da muss ich erst mal kurz zu suchen ob
ich dir noch finde also es ging darum
einen stoff elefanten den frauen die
kamera gezeigt hat und der den hat sie
selbst bezahlt suchen war das genau
entschuldigung ich probiere ich wollte
nicht jetzt hier besser wissen aber dass
wir können dann müssen dann leider das
wie der bgh hätte hier zu dem posten gar
nichts gesagt weil er stand da drin ist
richtig aber überragend groß und so aber
stand also da hätte ich jetzt gar kein
problem mit gehabt in dem konkreten
beispiel ich kann es vielleicht ein
bisschen beschreiben das ist ein perfekt
ausgeleuchtetes bild
da wird im zentrum des bildes wird eben
dieser plüsch elefant von der marken
firma hingehalten vors gesicht des
kindes auch ein hehres ziel das man das
nicht erkennen kann alles fein aber da
ist aus meiner sicht schwer einen
unterschied zu machen zudem zu einem
wirklich professionellen wärmebild das
hätte ich persönlich tatsächlich auch
anders entscheiden können
nichtsdestotrotz finde ich letztendlich
wenn jetzt diese dame in irgendwelchen
wagen klamotten privat rumläuft
vielleicht sogar selber das bild macht
das ist auch noch für mich immer so ein
anhaltspunkt wer hat schon immer so sein
fotografen dabei aber dann muss das in
ordnung sein wenn da mal eine marke
darauf zu erkennen ist dass man da nicht
zwingend wir haben wohin schreiben muss
in dem konkreten beispiel und deswegen
ist es auch so mit dem mit dem kleinen
elefanten so weit gekommen sind hätte
man das vielleicht nicht bis zum bgh
getragen fand ich hatte es schon
es war dann mehr so die werbung für sich
selber so muss man das sagen also nach
dem motto liebe firma mit dem gelben
knopf im ohr kommt darauf mich zu und
schließt mit mir marken verträge ab und
da hat der bgh auch nicht ganz falsch
aus meiner sicht aber gesagt nee das ist
eigentlich erkennbar dass jemand der
hier in der öffentlichkeit steht blaue
haken 400.000 oder was auch immer
follower das ist nicht der völlig
überraschend dass derjenige vielleicht
um neue aufträge buhlt und dafür um sich
selber zu haben muss ja nicht unbedingt
ganz zu schweigen so ich habe etwas
gefunden das tut mir wirklich leid dass
ich seine recherche fehler gemacht habe
ich habe das posting jetzt fliegen
können wir noch mal kurz uns angucken so
sieht es aus also
da hat frau hummels quasi jetzt recht
bekommen sie musste das nicht als
anzeige kennzeichen obwohl sowohl die
firma als auch der elefant das produkt
gut zu sehen ist aber sie gibt halt
andere kein geld bekommen und von daher
ist das so in ordnung jetzt gibt es
arbeiten eine gesetzesnovelle
von der ja viele influenza erinnern
hoffen dass das dann mal mehr klarheit
bringt sehen sie das dann auch so
im grunde genommen ist es ich hab sie
mir extra auch noch mal ausgedruckt weil
da kommt es dann darauf die buchstaben
genau an das ist auch eher eine bessere
beweis regelung und geht mehr oder
weniger an die richtige in dieselbe
richtung da wird eine vorschrift aus dem
gesetz gegen unlauteren wettbewerb
dahingehend geändert also das schon
vorher drin man darf nicht in die irre
führen und man darf die leute nicht
irgendwie über den kommerziellen inhalt
täuschen dass daraus abzuleiten mehr
oder weniger und da ist jetzt
mittlerweile geregelt wurden das
unlauter auch handels wer den
kommerziellen zweck einer geschäftlichen
handlung nicht kenntlich macht
und dann kommt irgendwo ein bisschen
weiter später
kommerzieller zweck ist immer dann
anzunehmen wenn der handel ein entgelt
oder eine ähnliche
ähnliche gegenleistung dafür enthalten
hat da sind wir aber genau an dem punkt
wo wir eben gerade oben waren das ist
wahnsinnig da muss die praxis ist doch
zeigen was du daraus macht da kann man
jetzt nicht sagen oh das ist einfach zu
handhaben leider hab ich danke ihnen für
ihre fachlichen expertise und die
erörterung dieses urteils wie gesagt die
begründung lässt noch auf sich warten
dann wissen ein bisschen mehr bisher
können wir schon mal feststellen dass
frau hummels hier recht bekommen hat und
die ist uns auch jetzt zugeschaltet und
wartet schon die ganze zeit hallo frau
hummels freut mich dass sie da sind
so das war jetzt ein langer weg für sie
bis bis zu diesem urteil haben sie damit
gerechnet dass sie recht bekommen dass
der bgh in ihrem sinne urwald
also ehrlich gesagt ich habe gehofft
dass ich recht bekommen wir recht haben
und recht bekommen das sind zwei
verschiedene paar schuhe muss man ganz
klar sagen und ich habe mich tierisch
gefreut wirklich also zweiten prozess
dagegen bei mir in meinem fall fast vier
jahre lang und das war schon sehr
nervenaufreibend und das wollte ich
gerade fragen wie ging es ihnen jetzt in
der zeit vor dem urteil ich habe ihre
story heute genommen das ist ihnen nicht
so richtig doll denn bis hierhin ja ich
hatte ein bisschen probleme mit meinem
magen aber das ist auch klar ich meine
wenn man wirklich vier jahre lang
gekämpft hat ich habe wirklich viel zeit
investiert auch geld was für mich in der
hinsicht nicht an erster stelle stand
weil ich habe gesagt ich kämpfe für
meine recht also das war einfach den
kampf den ich geführt weil ich wusste
dass mit der unrecht getan wird und
trotzdem wusste ich aber nicht schaffst
du es rentiert sich das die ganze zeit
auch
ich sag mal das war alles so
nervenaufreibend ich wusste es einfach
nicht und deswegen war ich heute
natürlich besonders angespannt bzw seit
gestern weil ich wusste am 09 da ist es
dann soweit und ja jetzt geht's wieder
gut ich glaube ich schlaf weiterhin aber
können sie das nicht so ein bisschen
nachvollziehen wir haben das foto ja
jetzt gerade gesehen ich habe erst ein
falsches foto gezeigt habe ich das
richtige gefunden mit dem elefanten das
dann manche sagen hey kommen das sieht
echt wie werbung aus wieso schreibst es
nicht einfach drunter von mir aus auch
unbezahlte werbung ich habe ja auch ein
kommentar gefunden von wk mainz sowie
der standby markennamen oder beim namen
genannt der produkt- oder wenn man sie
sehen kann einfach drunter schreiben
anzeige werbung nicht bezahlt so wäre es
nicht eine lösung wo man sagen kann okay
damit kann ich leben
also ich kann es nachvollziehen aber ich
mich mehr das kann ich mich steht an
erster stelle meine glaubwürdigkeit und
meine authentizität und wenn ich geld
ausgebe für einen produkt also mein
eigenes geld woraufhin auch steuern
gezahlt habe da möchte ich das einfach
aus freier überzeugung empfehlen dürfen
dürfen die fernseh medien suchen die
printmedien genau so und ich sehe mich
da eben als frauen zeitung wenn ich geld
bekomme oder wenn ich eine ausstattung
bekomme schreibe ich auch anzeige
darunter also das ist für mich ehrlich
gesagt klar und da appelliere ich auch
an mein eigenes verantwortungsgefühl und
kann aber auch nachvollziehen das ist
natürlich schwierig ist aber wenn man
transparenz will dann funktioniert es
meiner meinung nach nur so weil die über
kennzeichnung ist ja auch nicht
transparent
da bist du ja eigentlich genauso an der
nase umgekehrt sind sie denn jetzt
zufrieden mit dem urteil ich meine wir
haben gerade schon von herrn th gehört
so richtig eindeutig ist dass im
endeffekt nicht und es wird dann doch
immer wieder auf den einzelfall an
kommen also haben sie nicht doch die
sorge dass es in der nächsten zeit dann
doch immer wieder mal zu anzeigen kommen
könnte
ehrlich gesagt was in zukunft passieren
wird das weiß ich nicht ich hoffe aber
dass mein urteil jetzt erstmal
wegweisend war dass ich ein
weiterer gerät